- Good morning.
For many of you, this might
be your first re:Invent,
or maybe first day at re:Invent,
or maybe the first session.
I'm not sure whether this is
first silent session or not.
Everybody's comfortable with the headset?
You know how to control volume?
Great, thank you and welcome again.
Thank you for joining us
today for next 60 minutes
as we unpack the agentic AI story.
And here is a thing, you are
hearing the story from humans
and not from the agent.
Maybe at least for now, we
don't know what will change.
Imagine a world where AI doesn't need
to wait for instruction.
It can take initiative,
it anticipates your need,
make decisions, and act on your behalf.
Agentic AI is bringing in that shift.
Agentic AI is transforming
organization like yours
from automation to autonomic.
Today, we will show you
how agentic AI vision,
is delivering meaningful
business outcomes,
and real business results
that matters the most.
My name is Sujal Shah.
I am senior customer
solution manager with AWS,
along with me, Hamed Shahir,
is director of AI and data
science at Siteimprove,
and Pradeep Sridharan, senior
solution architect at AWS.
In this session,
we will focus on three
most critical elements
that actually unlocks
power of generative AI.
First and most important
is move beyond the hype.
Today, AI landscape is
filled with noise and hype.
We will explore how to
cut through that noise
and identify the AI initiatives
that aligns with your
unique business goals
and strategic differentiation.
This is important,
rather than chasing every
new technology trend
or focus on trying new use cases.
Once you identify the most
important AI initiative,
the next important thing is journey.
How you will take those initiatives
from idea to production at scale.
Hamed will walk us through
Siteimprove journey,
and he will show us how Siteimprove,
has convert their bold ideas
into production-ready solution
that is already delivering result
to their customer working
alongside with AWS.
And third, Pradeep will walk us through
how AWS GenAI services is
providing everything you need
to be successful with agentic AI.
From foundational capabilities
to production-ready workload,
it enables you to build
and manage enterprise-grade
agentic solutions at scale.
Let's start with something fundamental.
What is the most important
thing for your business today?
Most likely, your answer will point,
towards the core business principles.
For example, customer focus,
operation efficiency, product innovation,
strategic differentiation,
personalized experience,
and so on, right?
None of this fundamental
business principle change,
but what is changing
and changing rapidly is
how you are delivering
on those principles.
Generative AI and agentic AI
is fundamentally transforming
how value is created and delivered.
It is shifting from reactive workflows
to proactive outcome-driven system.
Agentic AI systems empower
businesses to innovate faster,
respond in real-time,
and stay ahead of changing
market requirements,
market dynamics and customer needs,
and that put you towards
a profitable growth.
The level of empowerment
and enablement it creates
for businesses definitely sounds powerful,
but the main question is
what do we really mean
by agentic AI, and how it is different
from traditional automation system
that many of us have been
using for decades too
to deliver on our core
business principles?
Traditional automation
relies on predefined rules.
Generative AI responds to prompts.
Agentic AI goes further.
It plans, reason, take
initiatives independently
to drive outcomes.
Agentic AI systems are
designed with intent.
They think and focus
in terms of objectives
and not just executing instructions.
Agentic AI acts autonomously.
It sets goals, dynamically
adapt strategies
for the given context.
It has been interesting to watch
how GenAI is evolving into agentic AI.
GenAI generate contents.
You provide a prompt,
it produce an output,
either a paragraph,
image, or line of code.
Definitely, it is very powerful,
but it is wait for your next instruction.
GenAI agent took this
further by breaking down task
into smaller steps.
Agentic AI system has evolved
into fully autonomous multi-agent system.
Agentic AI systems are capable
of executing complex multi-step workflow
by dynamically adapting strategy
to changing environment.
Most importantly, it can do all this thing
without any human or
external intervention.
Definitely, agentic AI
sounds transformative,
and it definitely offers real potential.
Understanding what is agentic AI,
is maybe a relatively easy task,
but the real challenge and the
most important thing is how?
How organizations are adopting it,
how do they operationalize
agentic AI with scale,
and with a clear path to measure value,
with a clear path to outcomes,
with a clear path ultimately
towards monetization?
Agentic AI adoption is
definitely accelerating fast.
Gartner predicts that,
"Within just one year,
40% of enterprise applications,
will embed task-specific agentic AI."
Fast forward in three years,
autonomous AI will handle up
to 15% of daily work decision,
and in next 10 years, by 2035,
agentic AI-driven software is expected
to capture approximately 35%
of enterprise application revenue,
and that is roughly surpassing
$450 billion dollar.
Now, think about this.
When we say 40% of
enterprise applications,
will have agent AI-specific embedment,
that is not a pilot metrics
that talks about the real adoption.
And when we say 30% of
enterprise revenue will be driven
by agentic AI solution,
that is not just an add-on.
That is product itself,
and that's how the industry
is adopting agentic AI.
There are two powerful ways
where businesses are leveraging
agentic AI and GenAI.
These two powerful ways
are operational improvement
and product innovation.
Operational improvement.
This is basically
streamlining how you build,
market, sell and scale
your products, right?
Agentic AI reduce friction and
it enables efficiency gain,
that free up capacity.
Product innovation.
Product innovation is
transforming what you do
or what you do to offer
your better differentiation,
enhance customer experience
and greater adaptability.
Agentic AI unlocks new capabilities
and competitive advantage
and that brings in new
or net new revenue stream.
Together, this create a very
powerful business dynamics,
cost-saving from efficiency,
plus new revenue stream from innovation.
This is how you sustain
growth in AI first era.
In the early adopter,
and most of the thing,
what we are seeing today,
businesses are focusing on
operational improvement,
but the real power comes
from product innovation,
and we need to balance both
operational improvements
and product innovation.
The balance between
this renewed efficiency
and new growth creates
investment opportunities,
and you know that there is no shortage
of AI investment ideas, right?
You do any hackathon, you
any brainstorming session,
you will get laundry list of ideas.
So the real challenge is not
to identify the ideas and opportunity.
The real challenge is identifying
which opportunity truly moves
the needle for your business
with the high impact use cases
that advance your unique business goal,
that advance your business outcomes,
and not just spreading investment thin
on low-value experiments.
So the question becomes,
how do you prioritize your AI investment?
We know that fundamentals don't change,
and one of those fundamentals
is working backwards.
Working backwards is Amazon mechanism
for prioritizing investments
by starting with customer outcomes,
and then decide which one truly
worth building and funding.
Not all opportunities are equal,
start with business outcomes and metrics,
and then you work backward.
Evaluate each opportunity's
value potential,
against effort required to deliver those.
Let's break this down into a framework.
You start with quick win,
a high-impact opportunities
with low effort,
and this will help you build momentum,
and achieve early result.
In parallel, you focus on
your most strategic bets
and initiative that holds
the highest potential.
Avoid investing resource-heavy
effort intensive project
that can only deliver moderate results.
As your AI and data maturity grows,
keep an eye on emerging opportunities,
and only prioritize those
that can help you build scale,
and after all, measure
all these opportunities,
against three important metrics,
trust, speed, and adoption.
Trust.
Ask this question, do these
opportunities help you build
and sustain customer trust?
Speed.
Can you move fast at scale
and not just solving today's status quo?
We are not just solving short-term goals,
but whatever you decide to do,
can you do it at scale?
And adoption.
As you know, adoption is
the most important metrics.
Without adoption, trust and speed,
they don't matter, right?
Adoption means whatever product
innovations you are doing,
are your customers using it?
Not only just using it, but
are they delivering any value?
And once they start using
and start delivering value,
do you see a path towards monetization?
So the structured approach
keeps AI initiative focused
on what truly moves the needle.
You can maximize your
business with managing risk.
Naturally, there are concerns
about converting effort
investment into growth potential.
Here, agentic AI act
as a force multiplier.
It enables organization
to unlock powerful growth trajectories
with meaningful investment.
Think of agentic AI as
your strategic fulcrum,
with the right foundation,
investment in infrastructure and talent,
you gain leverage.
With a clear growth
vision, new revenue stream,
differentiated product,
sustainable competitive edge,
you set the direction, but the
real impact comes from speed,
how quickly you can
convert this opportunity
and stay ahead of market
dynamics and customer needs.
Yes, it is practical reality
that agentic AI requires
upfront investment
and maybe some short-term trade-offs,
but with clear strategy
and discipline execution,
agentic AI becomes force multiplier,
takes you beyond incremental gain,
unlocking transformative growth
from every major investment.
So invest in the right foundation,
set the clear transfer with your vision,
prioritize quick win that
can help you build momentum,
and achieve early result.
That will put you on a path
towards turning investment
into realized value.
And then slowly, you can
accelerate on your go-to market.
This leads towards lean
investment and exceptional result,
and this is how winning enterprises
are adopting agentic AI.
Now, we know how to stay focused,
avoid distractions from
every new technology trend,
avoid distractions from new announcements,
happens every day, right?
Framing the opportunity that aligns
with your unique business goal
and force multiplier effect.
And that's not the end.
The real game is how to
take these opportunities
through the implementation
funnel and land solutions
on your customer hands.
Let me invite Hamed to walk us
through Siteimprove journey,
transforming the bold ideas
into production-grade solutions,
leveraging AWS capability.
Hamed.
- Thank you.
Hello everyone.
This is Hamed, and I'm very excited
that I'm representing Siteimprove today,
and share our AI journey from
generative AI to agentic AI.
A short introduction.
Siteimprove is a software
as a service platform
and a company that helps organization,
ensure their digital
presence is accessible,
compliant and highly performing.
They combine digital
accessibility, analytics,
SEO, AEO, and content strategy
into one integrated platform
called Siteimprove AI.
And we typically serve
medium-to-large enterprises,
government agencies,
educational institutions,
financial services, healthcare,
and any organization with
substantial digital footprint
who cares about the
quality and performance
of their digital content.
But what do we really
mean by a unified platform
for agentic content intelligence?
So we have AI agents and
solutions in four different areas
as I mentioned; accessibility,
analytics, SEO, and contents.
Our accessibility platform and agents,
big continuous compliance
into your workflows
and ensure accessibility
across web, mobile,
social, documents, applications by design
and not by accident.
Siteimprove agent assist every
designer, developer, editor
to make sure content is
accessible by default.
We help identify and fix
accessibility issues,
maintain site quality and
meet critical standards,
ensuring a seamless digital
experience for all users.
When it comes to analytics agents,
we want to stop sifting
through raw dashboards
and focus on what matters most.
These agents translate
traffic and page insight
into clear next step,
prioritize a tie to your business goals.
In other words, advanced analytics
as well as the user behavior
turns into actionable insights.
And our purpose here is
by continuously improving the performance
with our AI-driven intelligence,
your business stays
ahead of the competition
and maximizes ROI.
So we have SEO agents,
the purpose is to outshine the competition
in search engines, LLMs and AI search.
Each agent support SEO
leads and content owner
to basically by offering real-time
guidance and optimization
through the content creation process
to boost visibility and discoverability.
This is very important.
We harness power AI-driven tools
to ensure that your
content not only aligns
with your business goals,
but also, is discoverable
across different search engines.
And last, content agents helps planners,
writers and strategists
through their every phase
of content ideation,
planning, briefing and optimization,
and basically, tries to close
the gaps between your content.
But this is not the end.
We also need orchestration agents
to work across the
Siteimprove AI platform,
and agnostically, integrate
with your ecosystem such as CMS.
So agentic AI adoption, and
why this is very important
to have a successful agentic AI adoption.
We all know that AI is super
easy when it comes to POC.
You see high school kids are
playing with these tools,
plugging them, but it's
very hard when it comes
to production and at scale.
There are two key
challenges here, we believe.
One is driving non-deterministic AI models
to deliver more deterministic
and consistent output.
And the second challenge is
when people start avoiding,
basically, the error rates.
We should not underestimate
the error rates,
when we are thinking about scaling.
As an example, you may think,
"Oh, my system is working
99% correct and perfect,"
but then we are scaling to 100 million
or more requests per month,
that translates into 1
million requests submitted
to AI getting error, and
that is the big challenge.
So now, I should say,
the way that we see this AI adoption,
is not a big bang moment,
it's more like a trust curve.
And at Siteimprove, we
do this in three steps.
In the first step, human is in the loop,
and that means AI and
human work side by side.
AI suggests, explains and validates,
but the human is the final
decision-maker, and it approves.
This is where we prove the
value of our agentic solutions
with higher quality, faster delivery,
fewer errors, and measurable impact.
The next step is to go
from human in the loop
to human on the loop.
Here, we still have the
human in the picture,
but not as an operator.
It's more like as a governor.
So it overlooks or the AI
basically does most of the job,
and the human only governs
the overall process.
The next step is human out of the loop.
And this is when we are
fully automating our process,
and when the trust is there.
But generally speaking,
we should not move
forward to each next step,
before answering two main questions.
Do users trust the system,
and has the system proven its value?
Because if you skip the
trust, adoption stalls,
and if you skip the
value, trust never forms.
And this is the biggest
challenge that we have.
So this is the three-layer
agentic AI adoption
that we are trying to do at Siteimprove.
But what agent AI really
means at Siteimprove.
Let's get into this.
It's very interesting
if you all search for
agentic AI definition,
you probably realize there
is no single definition
for agentic AI, and that's okay.
But everybody agrees that
intelligent agents are built
on core abilities like
plan, retrieve, act,
remember, understand, create,
specialize, recall, and customize.
And these are the core building blocks
that turn an agent from a chat interface
into a reliable digital teammate.
An agent is more like a
special assistant designed
for a specific task,
operate on those ability
to deliver consistent results.
But there is a key point here.
Having an agent, or even
having multiple agents,
doesn't automatically mean
that you have an agentic AI system.
Agentic AI truly begins
one system orchestrates,
multiple agents and technology
towards the same unified goal
and they work together,
and in an autonomous loops like a plan,
act, observe, adjust,
plan, act, observe, adjust.
It chooses the right sequence
of tasks, tools, models,
and make decisions
without human interaction
with the constant
communication with the agent.
So in the past 12 months,
we started from bringing generative AI,
and now we are at the agentic AI stage.
And now I want to share
part of our journey
and some use cases with you.
At first, with generative AI,
it's like having a brilliant assistant
who can create things for
you but only when you ask.
This is very similar to
a product that we have,
which is called brand consistency.
When the user comes and
ask, "Match, for example,
this content on this page
with the tone of voice
of my brand."
The prompt is fixed, the ask is fixed,
the generative AI model
generates the output.
Or when we have some accessibility,
rule checker goes and
check based on some prompts
and generates some fix.
Next is the AI agents.
In addition to generation,
now your assistant can make suggestion
and even take actions.
Agents are capable of taking
initiative, using tools,
integrating with other
part of your system,
and get the work done.
This is what we are currently doing,
and we have different systems,
such as conversational
accessibility or remediation,
or conversational analytics.
And the last phase is
basically the agentic AI phase
where your assistant becomes
more like a collaborative team
that can plan, coordinate
and adopt autonomously.
Here, multiple agents
communicate and work together
to solve problems dynamically.
You don't have to micromanage them,
they understand the goal,
they figure things out along the way,
and that is the agentic AI.
And this is our mission
to get these agents,
across all of our platform that
they can talk to each other,
communicate each other,
and get things done.
Before continuing this, I want
to take a moment to mention
that Siteimprove was
recognized as a leader
in the Forrester Wave for
digital accessibility platforms.
And this was a big achievement.
The Forrester Wave measures
digital accessibility vendors,
across the strengths of
their product offering
as well as the strength of their strategy,
and we advanced into leader
category in both axis.
And basically, we could achieve,
highest possible scoring 13 criteria,
including our innovation and vision.
This is the code from Forrester.
Siteimprove is unique from
other leaders in this market
because it provides accessibility
as part of a broader unified platform
that includes SEO, analytics,
and content strategy.
(audience applauding)
So our journey started from
content intelligence platform,
and now, we are going to
agentic unified platform.
But before I jump into
the actual use cases
and technical architecture,
I want to say why accessibility
engine is very important
for us if you don't know.
So accessibility is about
ensuring digital content works
for everyone, including 1.3 billion people
with disabilities, visually
impaired users navigating
with screen readers as well as users
with motor impairments
relying on voice commands.
Let's assume a page title is welcome
or a link says, "Click here,"
the experience is broken here.
And fixing these in production
is not as easy as you think,
because some of our customers
have 50,000 webpages
that needs to be crowded,
needs to be checked,
and there are some timeline.
So this is not necessarily
an AI challenge per se,
it's more about an orchestration
and infrastructure challenge.
Today, I'm gonna present three
of our interesting use cases,
and the reason I selected
these three use cases,
is each of them has its own pattern,
and we show how these pattern
is implemented in production.
The first use case is async
batch processing use case,
asynchronous batch processing.
When we try to automate
potential issue reviews
for accessibility, here,
we need to process millions of pages,
up to 100 million pages per month
for accessibility rule check.
And obviously, if you can do
this with an acceptable cost
and meaningful scale, this
saves a lot of time and effort
from your manual work.
Let's assume then you can
submit everything in a batch,
and you get the response in 24 hours,
you can submit up to 100 batches,
each batch 100,000 requests,
and in one day, you can achieve
10 million requests done.
And I show you the architecture
that we implemented for this use case.
The second use case is
conversational AI remediation
for accessibility issue.
This use case is a synchronous
conversational use case,
when the user comes and try
to fix any specific issue.
And if the user is not
satisfied with the response,
then it starts the
conversation with the agent
and get the work done.
The third use case is async
again, but now it's not batch,
because not necessarily
everything can work in batch.
Some of our task has higher priority,
and we need to deal with
high priority async requests
to be able to get the
response as soon as possible.
This use case focuses on
contextual image analysis,
which means we want to
understand the context
of that image is relevant to
the image, like an alt text,
or the heading on the top,
the caption on the bottom.
So before I continue to talk,
I wanna show you a one-minute video,
and then you get a better understanding
of what I'm talking about, for example,
for this conversational AI remediate.
So this is an interactive experience,
the user can go to the portal
and see the potential issues,
click on one of them to
understand what's going on.
The AI tries to understand the context,
and here, it says, "No
title for this page."
It reads the page,
makes sense of the page,
and try to come up with
suggestions alongside
with some explanation and best practices,
that you need to do something.
And then if you're not
happy with the result,
and if you have any further question,
you can ask the agent,
"Okay, can you tell me a bit
more about this situation?"
And the agent starts again
going to the history,
the context, and get the response back,
and send it back to the user.
Now, things are getting more interesting.
Before we start developing
and implementing any system,
it's very important to understand
the business requirements,
and this is even more
important for AI agent
and agentic AI systems.
Sometimes some
non-functional requirements,
can change things significantly.
I will review some of these
business requirements with you
so you have an idea of what's going on
and why we decided to go
with AWS and Nova model
and I will show the architecture next.
So we are operating in both US and EU.
So we need enterprise-grade security,
governance, and compliance.
We need multi-region
support for compliance,
scalability, and resilience.
We need multi-model API.
So we should be able to
have agentic solutions
as well as generative AI solutions.
It's very important for us to have access
to variety of leading models
including Claude, Llama,
Nova, and so on,
support for both batch
and interactive workloads,
and a good support for deep
and seamless integration.
But the most important
thing is flexible pricing.
We need to make sure we
can optimize the cost when
we are running at a scale.
When we looked into
the possible solutions,
Bedrock was a great pick
because Bedrock runs
in the same environment
and same VPC as the rest
of your architecture.
You have multi-region
support automatically.
Bedrock supports both
agent and generative.
You have a variety of
support for both batch
and interactive, deep
and seamless integration.
And when we were looking
into Bedrock solutions
and Nova models, at some point,
we realized, "Oh, some of the models,
for example, Nova Micro at
that time when we checked,
we had 75 cost reduction
compared to the leading models
at that time, for some of
the use cases that we have."
So it's very important
to select the right model
for the right problem,
and not take the best model possible
for a very tiny problem.
This is Siteimprove AI accelerator.
We designed this in a way to satisfy all
of our business requirements
as well as all the possible
use cases that we are aware of.
The top layer is Siteimprove applications,
and the bottom layer outside
of the box is the AI services
that we use like an Amazon
SageMaker, Amazon Bedrock,
like in Foundation Models, Bedrock Agents,
and even AgentCore.
What is inside, it's very high level,
and I go to the next slide
which shows you the details,
but then here we have
three main big components.
One is our batch manager, one
is our business logic manager,
which includes all the
prompts and parameters,
and all the details
about the actual problem.
And the last layer, which is
shared between almost everyone,
is AI service adapters.
So based on the case,
we want to talk, for example,
to a specific third-party model.
So we will have an adapter
there to talk to that model,
or have an adapter for
Converse API and Bedrock.
So this is the high level one,
but this is, I want to have a closer look,
and what do I really mean
by async batch processing?
And I'm not gonna talk
about too many details here,
but it gives you an
idea of what's going on.
Like, and we have an
async batch processing,
I already told you, and examples are,
for example, we want to know
if the HTML page title is
descriptive of the page or not,
or the heading of a section
is descriptive or not.
By batch processing, I'm
talking about millions
of pages per day, up to
100 batches of 100Ks,
turns to 10 million pages per day,
and we will have input and output queues.
Starting from the top left,
that purple circle ALB, the
request is coming to the system.
We have a lambda grabbing the request,
putting in a queue right away
without any further processing.
There is another lambda
after we have enough requests
in the queue, grabs them,
put them and group them in an S3 bucket,
make them ready for
batch processing Bedrock.
Every few hours or few minutes
depending on your load,
we have another lambda submitting
these batches to Bedrock.
We know the turnaround time is 24 hours,
so we watch for an event to get triggered,
and then we have two lambda
to grab the results each,
the one lambda grabs
the whole batch response
and the other lambda process
each of them, clean them,
do the post-processing,
and submit the results back
to another queue.
With this architecture,
we could achieve what I just explained,
like, in millions of requests.
And then think about what I
mentioned at the beginning.
I said I picked three use cases for you
to show you some patterns.
And this is what I mean,
this is our AI accelerator architecture
that's getting extended.
On the very right side,
that section is exactly
the what I just showed you,
and that's a batch processor unit.
In the middle part,
whenever we have some sort of
an interactive conversation
with some agents,
we have some lambdas to
talk to the Bedrock Agents,
around the conversation,
having conversation,
having revision for the
conversation, having remediation.
And on the very left,
you see the third use case
for contextual image analysis.
I take some time here again.
So the request is coming to this lambda,
the URL of the image gets
pushed to that queue when
we have enough requests,
a Bedrock requester grabs the
request, submit to Bedrock,
it's async but it's not batch.
So it submits back or
sends back the result
to the output queue and
the user is using it.
And now, think about this,
I have three pattern established
in my infrastructure.
So if I have like five more
use cases in the batch,
I follow the same pattern,
and if I have two more
use cases high priority,
I follow this pattern.
So we are trying to
build this architecture
to support all possible use cases
that we have in our business.
I want to double-click
on a very recent
development and a highlight
that we are now extending
our agentic framework
with AgentCore for
conversational analytics,
and why this is important.
I already mentioned,
we are thinking about
having a unified platform,
and the user comes to our platform,
and can ask questions from
different aspects of the system.
Think about this, user comes and say,
"What are the issues with
my top visited pages?"
We need to go to the
analytics of the website,
understand, or when I say we, the agent,
needs to go and understand,
what are the top visited pages
and what are those pages basically?
Then the agent calls
multiple agents to say,
"Okay, what's wrong with
the accessibility part?
What's wrong with the SEO part?
What's wrong here?
How the user can improve?"
So with this AgentCore architecture,
we try to connect the existing agents
into more scalable solution.
We have real agentic AI.
You'll see our AgentCore
Runtime is running
on a Strand Agent.
It some internal local tools
for query interpretation,
for formatting, for another
formatting for JSON and UX.
We can call other agents
through AgentCore Gateway.
As an example, we call our own MCP server
through the Gateway.
Each of these tools
can have Bedrock models
for their internal tasks,
and they all have access
to short-term memory
and long-term memory.
Short-term memory is usually
for session management.
Long-term memory is usually
for actor management.
You want to keep the
preference of the actor.
And in the next part of this presentation,
a party will go and explain
the architecture in depth.
Now, I want to start concluding my part,
and I want to share our
strategic milestone.
And the reason I'm sharing this,
I believe this is common
for many of other companies.
It's very important and
when you want to walk
into this journey, you first
prove values of your AI agents.
Lay the foundation with core use cases
in each pillar that you have.
Try to have reactive agents
which are the simpler agents.
The next step is then
to automate and amplify,
expand agents to take on
more repetitive complex
and high-volume tasks.
This is the time that you
enter proactive agents
and multi-agent collaboration.
And usually, the long-term goals
for many companies at this point is
to have more or less an autonomous
orchestrated intelligence
to be able to create agents data
and workflows across the entire platform.
During this journey, we
learned a lot of lessons
in collaboration with AWS,
and I want to share some of
these you make a benefit,
some of them are pretty technical,
some of them are more
kind of an administrative,
but it's very important
that you use cross-region
inference if you can.
It helps you to reduce latency,
improves resiliency, scales
throughput, optimize cost.
And basically, you are
serving your workload
from multiple regions.
The other challenge that many people have,
is effective prompt
engineering and optimization.
Bedrock has an optimization tool
that you can give your prompt
and the model that you
want to optimize for,
and it optimize the prompt for you,
and you should not underestimate this.
For example, when you are
working with one specific model,
maybe the best is to have XML tags
to structure your prompts.
But when you are using for Nova,
Nova, for example,
prefers markdown language
to structure your prompt.
If you do not optimize your
prompt for this specific model,
then things gets messy when
it comes to this scale.
The next is understanding
regional throughput
and quota variations.
This is super important that
you have an understanding
of your quota ahead of time,
especially if you are scaling.
Don't assume if you submit 200
million requests in a month,
it gets processed.
So you need to understand, for example,
what is your quota for
model inference per minute?
What is your quota per region?
What is your quota for the number of jobs
that you can submit?
And then estimate and
get help from AWS team
to get what you need,
not when you are going to
production, way ahead of time.
The next lesson learned for us was
how we can mitigate failed responses
by using different models.
You can have your architecture
to dynamically select the models,
especially, if you're using
one family of model like Nova.
If the response gets failed from Micro,
you can bump to Light,
from Light, you can go to Pro.
This can be done in real-time
if you have multiple models
or can be done when you
do your prompt engineering
and your analysis.
So you can have multiple
models running at the same time
for different use cases,
or have a real-time
escalation to the next model.
Mitigating model hallucinations
and enforcing restrict output formatting.
This is very important.
At the end of the day,
you want to show the
AI output to the user.
So you really need to have
probably adjacent output
or some structured format
that your UI, at some point,
can process and show it to the user.
There are several techniques
that you can force your agent
to come up with a very specific format.
And this is an ongoing
challenge, I believe,
for everyone when I'm
talking to different leaders.
Like, you can find guidelines,
like, in pre-filling, is one technique,
when in the assistant part of the prompt,
you start the beginning of
the output that you expect
and that force the agent
or the generative AI model
to continue on that, right?
There are multiple techniques
that you can learn,
but you should not underestimate this one.
And the last part,
is handling contextual
information in batch processing.
When we have batch processing,
we are dealing with millions
and millions of requests.
By contextual information,
I mean, metadata,
for example, the digest ID
for each of the requests.
So if you want to stay
stateless and keep everything
within the call to the agent or LLM
and get the response back,
you need to somehow pass part
of this contextual information
to the agent and get it back,
unless the architecture
that you're using supports
for these kinds of metadata,
which is usually not the case,
at least to this point, to
the best of my knowledge.
What is the challenging part
here is the hallucination.
I give you a very concrete example.
We realized we were using
a very specific hashing
or encoding algorithm
to hash my digest ID.
And whenever the agent
gets to the semicolon,
he was thinking, "Oh,
it's end of the line,"
and dropping the rest of the ID.
And then we had a lot of hash mismatch.
So you really need to
understand when you are working
at the scale, how you deal with
your contextual information
that you expect the agent
send it back to you.
Now, I want to pass it to
Pradeep for the next part,
and his presentation on AgentCore.
- Hello all.
My name is Pradeep Sridharan.
I'm a senior solutions architect at AWS.
At AWS, we have a simple
but ambitious vision,
to provide the best place to build
and scale the most useful AI agents.
Not just a prototype, but
actual production agent,
and not just any agent,
the most useful agent
that delivers actual business value.
This is what drove our work
that we did with Siteimprove,
and this is what is driving everything
that I'm about to show you today.
But before we go there,
let level set on what an agent is.
In a nutshell, an AI agent is a system
where an LLM receives goals,
maintains context, creates and uses tools,
learn from observations, right?
It's what you call as a continuous loop,
observe recent learn, and act.
It's very simple in concept,
but when executed well,
can be very, very powerful.
But executing this well is
not without its challenges,
and here is why.
Because agentic AI systems
are autonomous in nature,
even implementing a
simple agentic AI system,
takes a lot of moving parts, right?
You need to have a way
to do orchestration,
you need to have a way
to do tool execution,
and you need to have a way
to manage state, right?
Luckily, we do have frameworks today
that helps with a lot of
this uplifting, right?
We have Strands Agents
from Amazon, LangChain,
LangGraph, CrewAI, and so on and so forth.
But this open source
framework makes it easy
because they provide developed abstraction
for some of the pre-built codes.
But still, many organizations struggle
with getting from this state
to actual production system.
In fact, we have name for this.
We call this the
prototype-to-production chasm.
You can see on the left,
you have a POC that is working, right?
You have excitement and potential,
but you want eventually get to where
that very POC is running in production,
delivering actual business value.
But still, this is not
without complexities, right?
You have to manage memory systems,
because LLMs are stateless.
You have to manage security,
you have to manage governance,
and all of this needs to scale
as your enterprise scales.
Gartner predicts that,
"40% of enterprise agentic
AI projects will be canceled
by 2027 due to soaring cost,
unclear business value,
and security concerns."
This is the reason why we
built Amazon Bedrock AgentCore.
Bedrock AgentCore is our answer
to the production chasm problem, right?
It's a fully managed service
that handles everything you need
for running production agents.
You get all the leading models
that's available on Amazon Bedrock.
You also get access to orchestrators,
open source orchestrator,
just talk about LangGraph,
LangChain, so on and so forth.
But what makes AgentCore,
a real production-grade application is
what you really see under
the way we line, right?
You have secure runtime management,
memory systems that manages
both short-term memory
and long-term memory.
As Hamed mentioned,
short-term memory is primarily
for session management,
long-term is for active management.
Secure authentication and token storage,
secure tool communication,
and out-of-the-box observability,
so that you can understand
what your agents are doing.
So this is not just about
running one single agent,
but this is about running
a production-grade agent
that can scale to millions of users,
recover gracefully from failures,
and adopt to your needs as you grow.
I'm gonna pull back a little bit
and show how this services work together,
and this particular slide can
be a little bit technical,
be in the reads.
And I know this is a silent session,
so if you guys have any questions,
I'm happy to answer some
of the questions outside,
once the session is done.
But I wanna highlight
a few major components
of the AgentCore, right?
You have the Agent Runtime, Agent Gateway,
Agent Memory, Agent Identity,
and Agent Observability.
Agent Runtime is a secure
server-like runtime,
purpose-built for
deploying dynamic agents.
It's a remarkable runtime.
It supports multi-model agents,
scales from zero to thousands
of concurrent users in seconds.
And it also provides
complete dev isolation,
meaning, it has isolated
compute environments.
So data leaks are not a problem.
AgentCore Gateway converts
your existing APIs,
lambda functions and MCP servers
into tools that agents can use.
It provides a unified interface,
and has pre-built IAA authentication.
AgentCore Memory provides you a namespace,
encrypted namespace-based storage
that supports both long-term
and short-term memory,
and it's also quite powerful.
It supports multiple
extraction methodologies,
like semantic search and
namespace-based extraction.
AgentCore Identity solves enterprise
authentication challenges, right?
It provides a secure delegated
access control mechanism
for your agents, for third-party
applications like GitHub,
Salesforce, so on and so forth.
It also reduces development time,
because you can reuse
existing identity providers,
like Microsoft Entra ID, Okta Kognito.
It also uses a secure vault storage
that reduces content
authentication fatigue,
and provides a frictionless
user experience, right?
Now, AgentCore Observability,
is a comprehensive end-to-end
solution for observability.
You can use it to understand
your agent action,
look at reasoning and
input or output locks.
You can also build pre-built dashboard.
You can use pre-built dashboards.
And because AgentCore
Observability is hotel compatible,
it integrates with the number
of hotel compatible
application monitoring tools.
But AgentCore is just part of
our larger portfolio, right?
Amazon provides everything you need
to build and scale your agents.
I'm gonna start from the top.
At the top, we have applications,
you have Amazon Quick Suite.
This is our purpose-built
business application
for enterprises.
Kiro, our newly launched ID
for software development.
AWS Transform is again an agent tool
that is used for modernizing
legacy workloads.
Amazon Connect with the
agents for customer support,
and we also provide through
our AWS marketplace,
a number of agents and
agent applications provided
by your trusted partners.
In the middle, you see
our development platform,
you have Amazon Bedrock.
Now, Bedrock provides access
to a number of leading models
from providers like
Anthropic, Meta, Mistral,
and we have our own models, Amazon Nova,
which are essentially models designed
with agentic AI architecture in mind.
We also offer Nova Act,
which is essentially a model
that can take action
within a browser context.
We also provide AgentCore,
just talked about it.
It's essentially the best way
to run and scale your
agents in production.
We offer Strands Agents,
which is the open source Python-based STK
for developing your agents as well.
From an infrastructure front,
Amazon provide
infrastructure that can scale
from prototype to production.
The primary infrastructure is offered
to Amazon SageMaker AI,
and we have our own chips as
well, Trainium and Inferentia.
And now apart from this,
we also support open standards
like Model Context Protocol
by Anthropic and A2A,
Agent2Agent by Google.
Now, all of those could
be a little bit complex,
so I'm gonna leave you with
a simplified version of it.
There are really five
key takeaways, right?
We have pre-built agents,
so that you don't have
to start from scratch.
We have tools like code
interpreter and browser.
We have models like Anthropic
and Meta models that we offer.
We have infrastructure,
to scale from prototype to production.
And we also provide expertise,
which is essentially AWS
folks like me working
in context with your team to
achieve your business goals,
which brings me to the next slide,
which is essentially how we
are gonna engage with you.
Now, at AWS,
we don't just provide technology,
we also provide you a
complete support ecosystem.
Our one team model puts customer, you,
at the center of it.
We have full distinct teams.
We typically start with AWS account team.
So this is a team that actually works
with you day in and day out,
understanding your
business goals and vision.
I am actually the account
team expert for Siteimprove.
And account team typically
advocates for you
within the larger AWS ecosystem
to get you more access.
Then we have the GenAI Innovation Center.
So this is a team that provides
deep ML and AI expertise.
This is a team that actually
worked with Siteimprove
to help with some of the
batch processing challenges
and prompt optimization.
Then we have product teams
where we give customers access
to engineers working on Bedrock, Nova,
and AgentCore platforms.
This is so that you'll have
early access to features
as well as provide
roadmap influence, right?
And build and support your endeavors
and provide technical
account management as well.
And we engage with customers
in a variety of ways.
I have highlighted four here;
office hours, which typically
means recurrent calls
that we handle,
quick technical discussion,
deep engagements.
These are engagements like what
GenAIs did with Siteimprove
to kind of accelerate.
Experience-based acceleration,
this is another interesting mechanism
by which we work with the customer
on over-the-shoulder basis,
particularly, when they're
beginning something
to accelerate outcome for them.
And technical enablement
is when we provide training
and certification for you
and your teams, right?
So if you're ready to
start with your journey,
I'll leave you with a
framework to begin with.
So for any agentic AI innovation,
you have to start with business
outcomes in mind, right?
Like, define first your use cases,
and start from there.
The reason why Siteimprove
was so successful,
because they picked up accessibility,
which was essentially making
the most sense for them, right?
Once you have your use case defined,
then you can pick your models
and agentic AI framework.
And remember, with Bedrock,
you are not locked in.
You can change your mind anytime.
And once you have that information,
you can then have to
consider security compliance
and responsible AI upfront.
It's not an afterthought.
So once you have this,
create a proof of value,
not just a proof of concept.
And from there, you can
go in to development,
deploy and scale.
And remember, this is my agentic process,
you can learn and accelerate.
I'll leave you with four key takeaways.
Prioritize AI investment by
starting with business outcome.
We don't have to change every trend.
Like I said,
starting to focus on
accessibility and compliance.
Agentic AI transform
business beyond technology.
Yes, there are early challenges,
but the growth potential is enormous.
Third, bridge the
prototype-to-production chasm
through systematic value delivery.
Use tools like AgentCore when
possible to achieve this.
And fourth, build for enterprise success
with AWS #OneTeam collaboration.
You don't have to do this alone.
With that, thank you very much.
We are excited to help you build,
and scale the most useful AI agents.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)